the matrix resurrections is a movie
about making the matrix resurrections we
cannot emphasize this enough am i crazy
we don't use that word in here the end
of resurrections begins with a much
anticipated sit-down between neo and the
analyst their venue for this meetup is
the delightfully named simulate coffee
shop where thomas anderson has received
much of his stimulation over the years
and inspiration via a beautiful woman
named tiffany who bears a striking
resemblance to our old friend trinity
this tiffany has a lot invested in the
world she sees every day she has a
husband a job three children but also a
persistent feeling there must be more as
well as a relentless affection for
ducati motorcycles at the coffee shop
neo and the analyst finally lay all
their cards on the table and decide to
let her break the stalemate if tiffany
decides to stay tiffany neal will return
to the matrix once and for all and
become thomas anderson again if she
decides to become trinity all bets are
off the architect who says he likes
tests accepts saying we'll let tiff
decide breaking down the stakes the
grown-up sati sums up neo's dilemma with
a single line the most important choice
in neo's life
it's not histamine
after watching moss's character
essentially being lobotomized for most
of the film what comes next is
particularly satisfying as her husband
and kids make one last sales pitch it
appears that tiffany might return home
with them just as neo is being dragged
away however she delivers four words
that trigger the film's ending and
perhaps more matrix movies to come my
name is trinity
one of the more welcomed upgrades in the
matrix resurrections is the new agent
smith although hugo weaving was nothing
short of iconic in his work originating
the character jonathan groff does a fine
job as his new face at the end of
revolutions it looked as if both neo and
smith had been destroyed with
resurrections we once again see that
smith and neo's fates are tied to each
other as his boss becomes his enemy
graff's smith takes over in the key
matrix role of engaging neo in multiple
high-powered memorable smackdowns by the
end of the film it looks as if smith
might have been eradicated but when neo
and trinity need saving smith once again
returns from the dead this time to fight
on their side he substantially aids
their efforts in the simulate coffee
shop then vanishing once again he points
out to our heroes anyone could be you
whereas i've always been anyone
what follows is all the butt kicking
bullet dodging aerial acrobatic
choreography you would expect from a
matrix film this time with neo and
trinity backed up by a new crew led by
bugs as the group make their way out of
the simulate the analyst turns the
matrix against these viruses threatening
his creation in essence every human in
the area turns into a quasi-zombie
attempting to take down the heroes when
trinity shows up on a ducati and has
neo-hop on board this sequence gets
particularly striking as in hundreds of
bodies striking the streets down below
diving out skyscraper windows and
essentially turning themselves into
bombs attempting to hit trinity and neo
as they speed through the streets after
many close calls explosions and
imperiled colleagues trinity and neo
make it to their destination but what
comes next if people are truly to be
freed the analyst himself must be
confronted but with neo and trinity
united again and their minds freed
anything is possible
with that bit of business concluded and
agents closing in neo and trinity take
to the roof of a skyscraper where they
take a great leap of faith throughout
the matrix resurrections neo keeps
seeing the same recurring image of birds
in flight flying in some sort of time
loop we are also told that thomas
anderson tried to step off the roof of a
building at a corporate party but was
pulled back at the last moment an event
witnessed by bugs finally it becomes a
sort of running joke throughout
resurrections that people ask neo
whether he can still fly and he can't
make it happen all this builds to neo
and trinity literally taking a leap of
faith stepping off the top of the
building holding hands at first they
begin to fall and you'd be forgiven if
you just assume neo's old skills will
kick in and he'll save the day instead
it's trinity who discovers an ability to
fly reminiscent of neo soaring away at
the end of the original matrix this time
it's trinity who takes to the sky with
neo along for the ride
when the duo confront the analyst
together this time in his office the
power dynamic has shifted considerably
now instead of dictating the terms to
neo surrounded by dozens of his agents
he is on his heels and alone but that
doesn't stop the analyst from bragging
about his plans waxing philosophic about
the intrinsic shortcomings of mankind
and telling the duo time and again that
their efforts are useless as if to drive
home the point that he's the one
fighting the losing battle trinity kills
the analyst again and again each time
with him snapping back until he finally
seems to admit defeat at this point the
analyst seems to shift from saying
they'll never gain control to
essentially saying they'll hate the
burden of having control what are they
gonna do he asks rebuild everything with
rainbows in the skies as he puts it the
sheeple aren't going anywhere at this
point the newly reunited trinity and neo
resolve to do exactly that joking that
the rainbow idea actually sounds pretty
nice
if you stick around through the credits
you'll notice that when the title the
matrix resurrections is flashed on the
screen
it becomes the matrix resurrects could
this be the title of the next potential
film like the end of the original film
the final moments are soundtracked by
the uplifting rebellion rock of wake up
only this time rather than the ferocious
rage against the machine original the
cover version you hear is by a band
called brass against with help from
sophia urista unfortunately the
post-credits scene is a real
disappointment when the titles lift and
the screen lights up again we are
transported back to thomas anderson's
old place of work where his team are
still debating new marketing ideas and
ways to make money off the matrix
franchise as in the earlier scenes it's
all very meta someone says face reality
movies are dead games are dead narrative
is dead their solution create
programming for felines a series of
videos called the catrix and yeah that's
real the matrix resurrections is in
theaters now check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]